11h47 lundi 26 juin 2023 nous venons de
vivre un week-end rare où l'avenir du
monde a peut-être failli basculer
peut-être peut-être pas que s'est-il
vraiment passé à Moscou à Rostov sur le
front en Ukraine Vladimir Poutine a-t-il
tremblé le désormais célèbre priscogyne
est-il si fort qu'il le dit toutes ces
questions auxquelles nous allons tenter
de répondre ce matin avec Alexis ferchaq
merci d'être ici Alexis merci rédacteur
en chef adjoint au pôle actif du figure
alors que s'est-il passé
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé je pense
qu'il faut repartir de là parce que déjà
suivi en étant au week-end et puis
envoyer des alertes
de vendredi soir et pour tout vous dire
nous au journal on a commencé à voir les
ce qui était en train de se passer et
très vite on a compris que l'événement
était important on avait on avait aucune
idée de la de la fin et qui finalement
s'est résolu il y a encore énormément de
réponses qu'on a pas mais mais en tout
cas le moment c'est terminé à peine 24
après mais en tout cas un chef de guerre
comme prégogène qui est donc à la tête
d'une armée privée et qui s'en prend à
leur panormément à Vladimir Poutine mais
qui attaque aussi durement et qui est
déclare la guerre pour le dire je crois
d'ailleurs qu'il l'a utilisé le mot
guerre à un moment pour s'en prendre aux
commandements militaire russe et
notamment au ministre de la Défense
shoegout et au chef d'état-major des
armées donc le général guirassimov
c'était un événement spectaculaire dans
un état
on sait que Poutine a vanter la
verticale du pouvoir russe la stabilité
de de l'État tout ça tout d'un coup on
avait l'impression que ça implosé sous
nos yeux avec une question c'est est-ce
que c'était une mutinerie d'un chef
mercenaire ou est-ce que c'était une un
véritable coup d'État bon bah on a la
réponse aujourd'hui c'était plutôt la
mutinerie de quelqu'un qui était qui
était acculé parce que finalement c'est
ça le
il faut bien comprendre que prégogène
était coincé dans là où il était arrivé
en
Ukraine il y avait un bras de fer avec
le milieu de la défense et c'est ça
qu'il faut raconter aujourd'hui alors on
va analyser ce qui s'est passé d'abord
je voudrais qu'on reprenne presque
minute par minute le déroulé de ce
weekend de ce vendredi soir de samedi
puis après c'est calmé dimanche vendredi
soir donc annonce prise de parole vidéo
c'est ça
prigogne depuis des mois et le champion
de la communication donc il a une
communication très directe extrêmement
brutale mais mais qui fonctionne très
bien sur les réseaux sociaux et qui est
vraiment à l'opposé de la de la
communication très corseté du ministre
de la Défense russe et donc là il a fait
un coup d'éclat et il a appelé non pas à
renverser Vladimir Poutine mais il a
quand même à plaire à renverser le
commandement militaire oui alors
Poutine il prononce les noms de shoeigou
donc le ministre de la Défense et Gary
simov qui est le premier général
il a parfois critiqué Poutine mais il a
jamais appris que tendance à dire il
faut les renverser eux parce qu'il
trompe Poutine c'est presque ça qu'on
sait en fait ce qu'il faut comprendre
mais là il faut se projeter un peu en
arrière c'est qu'en fait au début il y
avait une concurrence entre Wagner avec
cette tête trigogine et le ministre le
ministère des armées russes donc les
forces régulières russes et cette
concurrence est transformée en haine en
deux à la mort
prégogène donc toujours sur les réseaux
sociaux se mettait à insulter shoyungo
mais dans des termes qu'on peut pas
répéter à à l'antenne et finalement ce
que en revanche prigogi n'avait plus de
marge de manœuvre parce que début juin
la bataille de bac mouth était terminée
jusqu'à backpoot les Russes avaient
besoin de Wagner pour prendre cette
ville
ukrainienne ou ceux qui étaient à la
manoeuvre c'était pas l'armée russe
c'était c'était Wagner d'accord et
ensuite début juin donc quel ministre
dit à prégogène il faut maintenant que
tous les groupes militaires privés en
Russie donc le principal c'est Wagner
signe un contrat oui avec l'armée
d'accord liant finalement Wagner n'est
plus une niche ministre elle devient
absolument c'était ça en fait l'enjeu
était là donc Prigogine aurait été privé
de son de son pouvoir Prigogine a dit
n'y a-t-il non à choy et le le la date
de fin
l'ultimatum de chez Hugo c'était fin
juin et donc là il faut savoir que les
troubles de Wagner quelques exceptions
près ne sont plus sur le front là en
Ukraine parce qu'elles se sont retirées
de la ville de backmouth elles ont rendu
les clés de la ville aux troupes
régulières russes et donc là il y avait
un point d'interrogation à quoi aller
encore servir les combats de combattants
de Wagner le renseignement militaire
américain avait estimé qu'au maximum
Wagner était monté à 50000 hommes oui là
hier trigogine a annoncé qu'il avait
25000 hommes avec lui s'il a annoncé
qu'il en est 25000 c'est probablement
qu'il y en avait moins euh donc si vous
voulez
prégogène
était coincé parce que ça son rôle au
sein de l'appareil sécurité russe
devenez fragile alors même qu'il était
devenu l'un des principaux protagonistes
de la guerre en Ukraine et donc là il a
il a tenté un coup de force mais si vous
voulez c'est pas les c'est pas les
hommes de prégogène qui aurait pu
renverser l'appareil il aurait fallu que
qu'il fasse un coup d'éclat et que
l'armée en tout cas des parties de
l'armée qui est des soutiens très haut
placé et qui entraîne la Russie
sur Youtube comment 25000 hommes peuvent
faire trembler Poutine les 25000 hommes
en soi ne peuvent pas je vais prendre un
exemple les les la fameuse colonne de
chars dont on a parlé
en quelques jours jusqu'à 200 km de
Moscou alors ça suffit
énormément de blagues donc les Russes ne
peuvent pas aller en trois jours à Kiev
en revanche ils arrivent à aller en 24
heures à Moscou c'est rigolo mais c'est
juste une blague parce qu'en réalité
quand on regardait dans le détail
c'était avant tout des blindés
léger c'était des camions militaires il
y avait finalement très peu de chars il
y avait quelque chose et 72 mais à
l'image de l'armée de Prigogine c'est à
dire que l'armée de Prigogine qui a été
très importante en Ukraine c'était de de
l'infanterie c'était ce qu'on appelait
les Allemands appelés des stormtroopers
des troupes d'assaut c'est pour le dire
autrement c'était de la de la chair à
canon mais c'était extrêmement que des
hommes que de l'humain ou presque pas
grand chose
c'était avant tout de l'infanterie il
avait quelques avions quelques chars un
peu d'artillerie des quelques hélicos
mais en tout cas c'était pas ses 25000
hommes qui pouvait renverser à eux seul
les tarus la Russie a montré toutes les
tendues de ses faiblesses mais pas à ce
point là en revanche je voulais dire
Poutine n'avait probablement aucun
intérêt à ce que ça se termine en bain
de sang donc ce qu'on a vu en réalité
c'est qu'il y a eu très peu d'échanges
de coups de feu il y a eu des
escarmouches
mais c'est tout et d'ailleurs
des avions auraient été abattus
il y a eu quelques hélico je crois que
de manière assurée il y en a eu trois
quatre
c'est pas rien non mais c'était un grand
événement encore une fois c'était un
grand événement en revanche on était
quand même on n'a pas atteint c'est une
certitude le point où Prigogine aurait
pu s'emparer du pouvoir et pour ça
vraiment il aurait fallu que le
les chefs militaires en Russie fassent
le pari de Prigogine et ils l'ont pas
fait et on a eu des indices de ça assez
rapidement il y a eu la vidéo de
sorovikin qui est le commandant adjoint
de l'opération militaire spéciale russe
en Ukraine et qui pendant très longtemps
comme shoyu erasimov et prigogi ne
pouvait pas supporter ce revikids
pendant longtemps a été un peu
l'intermédiaire officieux avec avec prix
Eugénie et puis il y a eu un autre cas
une autre vidéo d'un général qui était
le commandement le commandant adjoint
des VDV alors c'est les Frost les forces
aéroportées
et
ce général il y a pas mal avaient une
autorité assez naturelle sur les sur les
Mercedes de Wagner parce que beaucoup
d'hommes venaient de s'efforce là et
donc assez rapidement on a compris qu'il
y avait pas de signes notables de
renversement du pouvoir c'est de gens
qui commençaient à dire on va peut-être
passer du côté de privil ça ça n'a pas
eu lieu du tout et donc il s'est
retrouvé coincé à 200 km de Moscou la
question du jour pensez-vous que
Vladimir Poutine a gagné son bras de fer
avec Prigogine on y répond avec vous
Alexis ferchak Hector chef adjoint ou
pour l'actu du Figaro on oui allez-y je
vais faire une réponse de Normand et je
vais répondre indirectement aussitôt
Jean-Louis bourlange qui est le
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères à l'assemblée qui a une jolie
formule Poutine a gagné la partie mais
il a perdu la face c'est bien qu'il il a
gagné la partie c'est indubitable et et
à ce stade il reste pas grand chose de
brigogine je peux pas physiquement ça on
ne le sait pas encore mais en tout cas
politiquement politiquement il a marqué
les esprits donc s'il arrive à survivre
les gens souviendront de lui
mais malgré tout il n'a plus tellement
de d'effets de levier d'accord Poutine a
fait flancher dans ce bras de fer
frigojin mais la main n'a pas encore
touché la table complètement on n'est
pas encore sûr en tout cas pas au même
niveau c'est que il a réussi sur le plan
opérationnel ce qu'il a réussi à faire
Poutine sans bain de sang
c'est finalement intégrer ce qui restait
des troubles de Wagner dans l'armée
russe ça il a en gros le deal le contrat
c'est que les mercenaires de les
mercenaires de Wagner qui n'ont pas
participé au putsch doivent signer un
contrat avec l'armée régulièrement russe
et ceux qui ont participé au putsch de
près de loin ne seront pas
poursuivialement c'est ce qui a été
annoncé en tout cas pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont bien servi la la Russie par
le par leur fait de guerre mais donc
voilà Prigogine
se retrouve sans son armée privée de son
armée en revanche pourquoi est-ce que
Poutine a perdu la face mais parce que
c'est quand même extrêmement humiliant
d'avoir une colonne de blindés qui
arrivent à 200 km de Moscou
qu'on le veuille ou non ça ça montre les
divisions les faiblesses et la fragilité
peut-être même la fébrilité du régiment
c'est ça c'est une il a gagné son bras
de fer selon 39,63% des internautes du
Figaro donc non qui ne sont pas d'accord
pris goji n'a perdu fin alors voilà en
revanche est-ce que petit a perdu dans
la ferme oui il a perdu au passage on
continue à remonter le fil des
événements trigogines vendredi soir
déclare qu'il faut faire tomber les
dirigeants militaires militaires que se
passe-t-il ensuite on apprend qu'il
s'empare d'une ville Rostov c'est ça
elle laisse de la Crimée c'était
important sur le plan tactique même pour
la guerre en Ukraine parce que si vous
voulez c'est un peu une base arrière
pour la logistique russe quand même on
le voit sur cette carte pour ceux qui
nous regardent sur le site ou nord-est
de la de la Crimée à l'est de la mer
d'Azov
et donc en fait il venait à peu près du
Dombas il y avait des bases de de Wagner
même si elles étaient plus sur le front
il y avait toujours les soldats là-bas
et ils sont allés à rostof voilà et
simplement ils ont entamé leur marge
vers Moscou alors on avait les dépêche
qui tombaient les tweets parce que tout
ça a été filmé avec une politique de
communication derrière évidemment
est-ce que c'est surtout là-dessus qu'il
a été fort frigo d'une équipe il est
fort depuis le début la communication
si on aime son genre de communication
non mais il est qui veut faire passer un
message
et d'ailleurs je remarque pendant la
bataille de bakemouth tous ces petits
communiqués quotidiens avec un certain
impact c'est à dire qu'ils étaient
repris
y compris dans la presse occidentale
alors que les rapports quotidiens du
ministère russe de la Défense
franchement personne n'avait envie de
les de les écouter ils n'étaient pas
repris alors il s'empare de Rostov et
donc samedi matin prise de parole de
Vladimir Poutine c'est très court très
court il ne prononce pas le monde
prégogène mais il parle d'un couteau
dans le dos couteau dans le dos alors on
peut ça fait l'expression de poignard
dans le dos fait penser à la à la
rhétorique de Hitler parlant de la
Première Guerre mondiale et de la fin de
la de la Première Guerre mondiale
c'est-à-dire l'idée finalement qui a une
guerre en cours et que c'est
une partie de la population intérieure
qui met un coup dans le dos des soldats
qui se battent sur le front et donc
Poutine joue cette cette stratégie à
fond
et là dans ce cas là il est assez
belliqueux il dit on ne laissera rien
passé
sous-entendu la traîtrise on ne peut que
la peut que la combattre et finalement
quelques heures plus tard
on annonce qu'il y a finalement un
accord qui a été passé via
l'intermédiaire de Lou cacher nko donc
le attend dictateur et président de la
Biélorussie alors dans ce laps de temps
et c'est la question qui est sur ce mur
Poutine a-t-il tremblé vraiment est-ce
qu'il y a une inquiétude et est-ce que
les Russes ont trembler est-ce que parce
que j'entends finalement les Russes ils
connaissent pas forcément très bien pris
goji savent pas forcément tout ce qui
sait les Russes aujourd'hui
en fait ce qui est très important de
comprendre c'est comment
un chef de guerre mais de petites
guerres normalement Wagner au début
c'était des mercenaires qui devaient
mener des opérations de déstabilisation
c'est l'échelle dans les pays d'Afrique
devait en aucun cas devenir une armée
entière qui devait tenir une part
considérable d'un front de mille
kilomètres dans une guerre de haute
intensité qui est une des plus violentes
guerres et donc en fait il est devenu
par ce fait il est devenu une figure
politique en Russie d'autant que il faut
bien savoir ça peut paraître difficile à
entendre en
Occident mais Poutine n'est pas du tout
le plus nationaliste en Russie et donc
il a à sa droite et d'ailleurs à sa
gauche parce que c'est le cas également
du Parti communiste il a sa droite des
nationalistes qui considère que Poutine
depuis le début de la guerre en Ukraine
à la main qui tremble militairement
et donc tout un tas de
personnes publiques en Russie qui dit
cela
et périgotide n'en faisait partie
pourquoi parce que
on remonte de quelques mois en arrière
l'offensive russe en fait c'est arrêté
au bout de deux mois à peine de 3 mois
ils ont atteint leur point culminant oui
à partir de là la ligne de front se fige
on réalise que les Russes ne sont plus
capables d'annoncer oui
se retire etc assez proche de KEF et
donc marche arrière
mais surtout ensuite les Ukrainiens
passent prennent l'initiative et je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez il y a deux
régions où les Russes reculent c'est
Carson oui écarquises absolument et là
les Russes c'est finalement c'est
toujours le cas l'armée russe régulière
établit une sorte de ligne de défense et
donc l'armée russe elle n'est plus à la
manœuvre vers l'avant ou de manière
extrêmement localisée elle est sur la
défensive ce qui est extrêmement peu
glorieux et finalement le seul endroit
où les Russes ont été à la manœuvre ces
six derniers mois voire même plus
c'était à baccout donc le seul qui
pouvait dire heureuse regardez on
continue d'avancer c'était prégogène et
ses hommes et c'est pour ça que
en Russie les
c'est pas le cas en Occident évidemment
mais les hommes de prégogène sont vus
quand même un peu comme des un peu comme
des héros même si c'était une armée de
prisonniers et de de et pas parce que
l'armée russe en face ne paraît pleutre
et c'est dans le discours de pédagogie
ça revient quasiment tous les jours
c'était une armée d'incapables de de
gens peu courageux etc etc Alexis donc
cette
annonce de cette prise de parole de
Poutine et quelques heures après vous le
dites accords que s'est-il passé alors
déjà c'est très flou honnêtement c'est
très fou
peut-être qu'on soit un jour mais en
tout cas on n'a pas tous les éléments
officiellement c'est Loukachenko
lui-même donc le président de la Russie
[Musique]
était à l'initiative de cet accord entre
Wagner et la Russie alors que dit cet
accord et bien trigogine va en
Biélorussie
alors au début c'était il y avait pas de
poursuites contre lui la réalité c'est
que ce matin qu'on regardait dans les
dans les médias ruses dans les agents
staff par exemple officiel
il a bien été rappelé que l'enquête
était toujours en cours et toujours
ouverte contre prix goji et par ailleurs
pour l'instant on n'a pas tellement de
nouvelles de brigi mais on sait
probablement encore en Russie en tout
cas il y a pas de on sait pas où il est
ça c'était l'une des questions
on peut pas répondre on l'a vu partir
hier en 4K
entouré de quelques bateaux qui l'ont
salué
pour la ligne donc a priori il n'est pas
encore en Biélorussie en tout cas on le
sait pas donc ça c'était la première
partie de l'accord
c'était près le cas Prigogine maintenant
la deuxième partie de l'accord qui est à
mon avis était la plus importante
c'était que va-t-il devenir des
combattants de Wagner en Ukraine et là
parce que dans son allocution Prigogine
dise aussi que c'est soldats n'étaient
pas assez protégés mais c'est son
discours depuis le début à chaque fois
tous les jours il insultait
on a passé aussi et c'est pour ça qu'on
n'avance pas assez vite
à
c'est vraiment ça
c'était dans les dans les discussions
entre Poutine et brigolin en tout cas et
c'est là où entre guillemets Poutine a
gagné son bras de fer c'est probablement
qu'ils vont réussir dans les jours à
venir sauf retournement
soudain mais ils vont réussir à intégrer
ce qui reste de Wagner
[Musique]
aussi devenir petit les forces de Wagner
qui semblaient remonter vers Moscou vous
me dites que pas vraiment eu de panique
parce que pas d'armes lourdes pour
protester elles étaient sur un autoroute
d'une pelleteuse qui tente de fracasser
l'autoroute pour pas que les forces se
passent de d'un dépôt de carburant qui a
pris feu est-ce qu'on
il y a eu quelques événements de même
eu un instant ou les
Russes Devrent ils ont mal dormi ça
c'est une certitude
qui a échoué en tout cas jusqu'à
maintenant c'est un très grand événement
historique on parle quand même de de la
Russie qui est un pays membres du
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
qu'elle est quel pays qui a le plus de
tête nucléaires
d'un président qui est là depuis
1999 en tant que Premier ministre
[Musique]
enfin c'est pas rien comme événement
j'entends beaucoup ce mot je connaissais
pas masquer rovca c'est d'ailleurs dans
les dans les commentaires sur Youtube un
terme russe qui désigne l'art de la
désinformation militaire ce ne serait
qu'une
une vaste tactique
dans les réseaux complotistes sur les
réseaux sociaux
nage à écrire mais ça serait qu'un roman
voilà enfin en tout cas on n'a pas
d'éléments
visiblement les Américains étaient au
courant il y avait quelque chose qui se
tramait avec Prigogine et visiblement
Poutine aussi de depuis 24 heures ou 48
heures
avait quand même quelques quelques idées
de ce qui sera mais parfois il y a des
cirques c'est un grand événement
historique mais le plus grand événement
qui se passe en parallèle et dont on
parle peu et qui est le plus important
pour la Russie de l'année Poutine
c'est la contre-offensive
ukrainienne qui a lieu dans le même
temps en Ukraine et ça c'est un danger
pour la Russie qui est beaucoup plus
important merci Alexis d'avoir répondu à
cette question pensez-vous que Vladimir
Poutine a gagné son bras de fer avec
prix goji on continue justement à parler
on va parler de l'Ukraine je remonte
quand même cette carte là aussi Alexis
parce que ça vient parfois de certains
réseaux je monte cette carte en gros
Wagner était ici ils sont revenus à
Rostov sur le don ils sont montés vers
Moscou et puis tout à coup pris goji
direction la Biélorussie matin et enfin
voilà certains disent ils ont déplacé
25000 hommes de backmouth à la
Biélorussie juste au nord de Kiev pour
rattaquer
kievable possible
ça n'a aucun sens
n'a aucun sens on attaque pas Kiev avec
25000 hommes pour la ligne il faut le
dire non mais je veux dire la question
parce que je vois certains
millions et demi d'habitants je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez on avait fait des
livescore pour pour l'expliquer 10 fois
c'est pas avec une armée de mercenaires
de
de 25000 hommes si on a vraiment
Napoléon Wagner se retrouve à la
frontière ukrainienne et polonaise ça
c'est une question qui se pose
il joue aux échecs me dit anti cerveau
voilà c'est une question qui se pose
dites-le à Alexis c'est pas possible de
faire 25 dollars alors qu'il y avait des
milliers d'hommes au début du de la
guerre qui ont tenté de s'emparer de son
succès oui ce qui est mes cheveux je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez mais au
début de la guerre il y avait trois axes
trois axes les deux axes le long d'une
Nièvre et l'axe de punaise donc voilà
les ordres de grandeur ne sont pas là en
revanche qui est certain c'est qu'on ne
sait pas tout donc là où il faut rester
extrêmement prudent c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup de questions et il y a ce jour
très peu de réponses ça change quoi en
Ukraine vous avez commencé à évoquer la
question est-ce qu'il y a peut-être du
côté ukrainien dans le camp ukrainien
forme de sursaut c'est à dire tiens là
on a une occasion d'avancer parce que
les Russes sont complètement
désorganisés politiquement donc à court
terme non à court terme non parce que
c'est ce que je disais peut-être deux
jours de flottement là
les forces sur sur le front ont reçu des
ordres ont eu clairement des directives
ou est-ce que peut-être pendant deux
jours je crois que il y a eu on ne
répondait plus à Moscou il y a eu
quelques déclarations
l'idée générale c'est que ça c'est en
soi le signe d'une fébrilité du régime
russe mais à court terme militairement
ça n'a quasiment pas d'impact sur la
ligne de front
pourquoi parce qu'encore une fois bon
prix gaugine parle de 25000 hommes on
est même pas sûr qu'on avait 25000 et
depuis la prise de backmouth et le
retrait des forces de Wagner de
backmouth en réalité le rôle des
mercenaires de Wagner en
Ukraine le relie média était extrêmement
faible pas de changement significatif à
suivre donc vous me dites vous me dites
en Ukraine pourquoi la communauté
internationale une certaine manière et
les opposants Russes se sont ralliés
derrière prigogines alors que vous ne
sont pas tous pas tous certains ont dit
entre la peste et le Collard et en ce
moment il faut soutenir frigogine oui
que c'était pas forcément le plus
nationaliste Vladimir Poutine mais là
dans ce contexte certains se sont dites
arguments que de certains opposants
russes que je trouve quand même étonnant
qui est de dire
il ne peut rien avoir de pire que petit
donc tout est mieux que Poutine donc on
prend pringogine c'est un argument qui
me paraît historiquement très étonnant
malheureusement dans l'histoire il y a
eu des choses pires que Vladimir Poutine
et par ailleurs on le sait ça c'est du
présent on le sait qu'elle a droite de
Poutine il y a des gens beaucoup plus à
droite entre guillemets en tout cas
beaucoup plus nationaliste
que Vladimir Poutine et Prigogine fait
quand même partie de ceux même s'il a
jamais attaqué de nommément Poutine
faisait quand même partie de ceux qui
trouvaient que le président russe en
tout cas la politique menée en Ukraine
depuis un an était l'illustration d'une
main qui tremblait
donc je ne sais pas si ça aurait par
ailleurs je pense que les Occidentaux
qui effectivement ont rappelé que
c'était une affaire de politique
intérieure russe même si ça soulignait
la faiblesse du point russe s'ils ont
dit ça ouvertement c'est parce qu'il ne
voulait pas aussi donner
l'idée que les Occidentaux pourraient
être derrière la tentative de coups de
prégo parce que Wagner va mourir
c'est possible mais Wagner c'est une
coquille
dont on a beaucoup parlé depuis deux ans
mais peut-être qu'elle va ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il y a d'autres PNC
il y a d'autres sociétés militaires
privées dont on ne parle pas c'est vrai
d'accord on avait écrit un article à
quelques semaines sur une autre qui
s'appelle convoy et beaucoup plus petite
à ce stade
et cette haute société militaire privée
elle est plutôt tenue par par soyou
tous les oligarques ont un peu c'est une
manière aussi de se faire mousser de
participer à l'effort de guerre etc
en tout cas Wagner en
Ukraine n'a probablement plus tellement
d'avenir en tant que structure Wagner
après le pose rien inventer il y aura
probablement d'autres sociétés
militaires privées et en tout cas la
politique de déstabilisation de la
Russie en Afrique qui était le terrain
de jeu de Wagner
ça ne va pas arrêter et donc Wagner
d'une manière ou d'une autre plus autour
de l'Ukraine et de cette guerre mais en
tout cas la politique d'influence
militaire de la Russie continuera à
s'accès dans certains pays
c'est pas une entreprise qui est
enregistrée au gestes du registre du
commerce de Moscou
c'est quelque chose d'assez opaque et
nébuleux donc ça peut évidemment
réexister sous d'autres formes après
quelle sera est-ce que Prigogine dans ce
qui subsistera de Wagner aura le pouvoir
qu'il avait avant la réponse c'est non
Poutine dit qu'il avait perdu la face
sans doute ce qu'il peut sortir renforcé
on sait que souvent après un putsch
manqué on se la regarder
tentative de putsch et pour le coup il a
vraiment failli passer dans dans mon
souvenir ça s'est pas joué à beaucoup
l'avion présentiel turc avait décollé
quelques dizaines de minutes avant
l'arrivée des puccistes
[Musique]
Erdogan qu'on a enterré 10 fois vient de
gagner les élections en Turquie
certes avec une courte majorité mais les
a remportés
[Musique]
donc je pense qu'il faut faut être
extrêmement prudent quelle va être la
stratégie maintenant ce sera ma dernière
question tome de communication peut-être
de Vladimir Poutine dans les dans les
jours qui viennent il va devoir montrer
que c'est l'homme fort de Moscou que il
tient ses hommes là il va être obligé de
le faire Poutine sont principales
problèmes plus que privé plus que Wagner
parce que c'est de montrer qu'il n'a pas
perdu en Ukraine
[Musique]
vous avez tout ça en replay bonne
journée